EXECUTIVE ORDER TO SHORE UP THE
U.S. SUPPLY CHAIN.
BRET.
>> Bret: GILLIAN, THANK YOU.
PENTAGON HEAVILY INVOLVED IN THE
CORONAVIRUS RESPONSE AND SEARCH
FOR A VACCINE.
HERE TO TALK ABOUT IT IS DEFENSE
SECRETARY MARK ESPER.
HE JOINS US FROM THE PENTAGON.
MR. SECRETARY, THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
>> Bret: I UNDERSTAND YOU JUST
GOT OFF THE PHONE WITH THE
GOVERNOR OF NEW YORK,
ANDREW CUOMO.
CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT THAT
CONVERSATION?
THE GOVERNOR HAD BEEN WANTING TO
DEPLOY ARMY CORPS OF ENGINEERS.
>> LET ME SAY ONE THING FIRST.
I WANT TO ASSURE YOUR VIEWERS
THAT THE UNITED STATES MILITARY
REMAINS READY AND CAPABLE OF
DEFENDING THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,
PROTECTING THE NATION IN
SAFEGUARDING OUR INTERESTS
ABROAD.
IN THAT CONTEXT, OUR SECOND
FOCUS IS BENT ON SUPPORTING THE
PRESIDENT AND THE WHOLE
GOVERNMENT APPROACHED THE CORONA
VIRUS.
IN THAT CONTEXT, I’VE HAD A CALL
WITH GOVERNORS TODAY.
TODAY I HAD A CALL WITH
GOVERNOR CUOMO AND WE HAD A VERY
GOOD CONVERSATION.
HE’S INTERESTED IN GETTING THE
CORPS OF ENGINEERS ENGAGED.
WHAT HE SEES IS A DEFICIT IN THE
HOSPITAL BEDS IN NEW YORK STATE
AS HE LOOKS AHEAD TO WHAT MAY BE
COMING, I GIVEN MY FULL
COMMITMENT THAT WE WOULD GET THE
CORPS OF ENGINEERS UP THERE SOON
TO ASSESS THE PROBLEM AND SEE
HOW WE CAN HELP.
>> Bret: TODAY YOU ANNOUNCED
YOU WOULD BE GIVING 5 MILLION
RESPIRATOR MASKS AND 2,000
VENTILATORS TO HHS TO SLOW THE
OUTBREAK.
YOU ALSO SAID IT’S JUST A DROP
IN THE BUCKET.
WHAT ELSE COULD THE U.S.
MILITARY DO POTENTIALLY?
>> WE ARE LANDING IN A NUMBER OF
WAYS.
OFFERING UP VENTILATORS,
PROTECTIVE GEAR, SOME OF WHICH
YOU MENTION.
WE ARE MAKING AVAILABLE OUR
FIELD HOSPITALS AND OUR HOSPITAL
SHIPS AS THEY BECOME AVAILABLE.
WE CAN, WE HAVE A NATIONAL GUARD
THAT’S ALREADY BEEN ACTIVATED IN
THE 18 STATES.
NEARLY 2,000 GUARDSMEN ARE
AVAILABLE.
ALSO WE ARE DOING CONSIDERABLE
WORK IN TERMS OF VACCINES AND
THERAPEUTICS.
I HAD A CHANCE TODAY TO GO TO
FORT DIETRICH IN MARYLAND.
IT’S A WORLD-CLASS FACILITY.
THE U.S. ARMY HAS BEEN ON THE
CUTTING EDGE OF A NUMBER
INFECTIOUS DISEASES.
THEY HELPED WITH A SOLUTION TO
BOTH EBOLA AND ZIKA.
THEY ARE WORKING AGGRESSIVELY TO
COME UP WITH A VACCINE FOR THE
CORONAVIRUS.
>> Bret: WHAT ARE THE
ESTIMATES, TELL ME ABOUT THAT?
FORT DIETRICH.
WHAT ARE THEY SAYING?
IS ALONG THE SAME LINES OF A
YEAR TO 18 MONTHS OR ARE THEY
HOPING TO GET SOMETHING QUICKER?
>> THEY ARE STILL LOOKING AT 12
TO 18 MONTHS ALTHOUGH THERE ARE
OUTSIDE COMPANIES THAT THINK
THAT THEY CAN CUT THAT TIME DOWN
A LITTLE BIT.
THE U.S. MILITARY WOULD BE
STANDING BY READY TO SUPPORT AND
ACCELERATE ANY TYPE OF
PRODUCTION EFFORTS.
I THINK 12 TO 18 MONTHS IS WHAT
WE’RE LOOKING AT.
THEY ARE ALSO WORKING ON
THERAPEUTICS, WAYS TO ADDRESS
SYMPTOMS.
THAT WORK IS UNDERWAY AS WELL.
THE THIRD PART OF IT AND WE ARE
WORKING CLOSELY WITH HHS IS
ACCELERATING THE DEVELOPMENT OF
NEW TESTING MECHANISMS SO WE CAN
DO TESTING FOR AMERICANS IN
VOLUME.
THAT SEEMS TO BE VERY PROMISING.
>> Bret: U.S. MILITARY MEMBERS
MEMBERS, HOW WORRIED ARE YOU?
YOU HAVE NAVY SAILORS ON SHIPS.
YOU HAVE SOMEONE’S SUBMARINES.
OBVIOUSLY THERE’S A LOT OF CLOSE
QUARTERS WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
DIFFERENT ELEMENTS OF THE U.S.
MILITARY.
HOW WORRIED ARE YOU ABOUT THE
SPREAD OF THIS VIRUS?
>> I’M CONCERNED ABOUT OUR
FORCING FAMILIES.
THAT’S MY TOPPER READY.
-- TOP PRIORITY.
WE HAVE A YOUNG, ROBUST AND
HEALTHY ARMY, NAVY, AIR FORCE,
AND MARINES.
WE ARE ALSO TAKING A LOT OF
ACTIONS ADVISED BY CDC INTO
ACCOUNT, SUCH AS SOCIAL
DISTANCING, CHANGING OUR HABITS,
USING SANITARY WIPES TO WIPE
DOWN EQUIPMENT AND DOORKNOBS AND
THINGS LIKE THAT.
WE ARE TAKING A NUMBER OF
PRECAUTIONS.
WHEN YOU ESCALATE UP TO SHIPS AT
SEA, FOR EXAMPLE, WHEN A GROUP
GOES ABOARD, THEY HAVE 14 DAYS
AT LEAST BETWEEN STOPS, BETWEEN
PORT CALLS.
THEY ARE NOT TRANSMITTING THE
VIRUS IS SHORT.
WE ARE TAKING ANY NUMBER OF
MEASURES TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
PROTECT THE FORCE AND WE SUSTAIN
OUR ABILITY TO REACT AND RESPOND
TO ANY CHALLENGES OR THREATS.
>> Bret: MR. SECRETARY, I
GUESS THE QUESTION THAT I GET
MOST WE WILL DEAL WITH VIEWERS’
QUESTIONS IN THE SEGMENT OR TWO,
HOW BAD COULD THIS GET AND HOW
DIFFERENT IS IT FROM H1N1?
THE EXPERTS TALKING ABOUT THE
CONTAGIOUS NATURE OF IT, THE
FACT THAT THE ELDERLY AND ALSO
THE IMMUNE DEFICIENT REALLY GET
HIT HARD.
YOU HAVE BEEN IN THESE
CLASSIFIED BRIEFINGS.
HOW DAD COULDN’T GET?
>> I THINK WHAT YOU ARE HEARING
PUBLICLY FROM THE CDC IS WHAT
I’M HEARING PRIVATELY AS WELL IN
TERMS OF THE RANGE OF ESTIMATES.
I THINK THE DECISIVE ACTION
PRESIDENT TRUMP TOOK IN THE LAST
24 HOURS, 48 HOURS TO ASK THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE TO STAND DOWN,
STAY IN FOR THE NEXT 15 DAYS,
AVOID LARGE GROUPS.
HE WILL GO A LONG WAY TOWARDS
BREAKING THE CYCLE IF WE CAN AND
FLATTENING OUT THAT CURVE.
THAT’S ALL THE SAME THINGS I’M
HEARING PRIVATELY FROM OUR
EXPERTS.
FROM DOD’S PERSPECTIVE.
I NEED TO MAINTAIN THE FORCE,
MAINTAIN THE NATIONAL MILITARY
MISSION CAPABILITY AND WE ARE
TAKING ALL POSITIVE ACTIONS TO
DO THAT.
WE HAVE PLANS IN PLACE.
WE ARE IMPLEMENTING THEM.
WE WANT TO LEAN FORWARD AND
SUPPORT THE WHOLE GOVERNMENT
APPROACHED TO ASSIST THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> Bret: I KNOW WHERE WE ARE
NOW WITH THE GUIDELINES OUT OF
THE CDC, BUT HAVE YOU BEEN ASKED
TO LOOK AT OPTIONS, HOW THE U.S.
MILITARY WOULD DEAL WITH SOME
SORT OF NATIONAL QUARANTINE OR
FACTOR INTO THAT?
>> WHAT WE’RE LOOKING AT IS NOT
NECESSARILY A NATIONAL
QUARANTINE BUT HOW CAN WE HELP
AFFECTED AREAS, WHETHER IT IS
STATES OR LOCALITIES.
OUR FIRST LINE OF DEFENSE IS THE
NATIONAL GUARD.
I WAS A GUARDSMAN FOR MANY
YEARS.
THEY ARE DOING A GREAT JOB.
LIKE I SAID CAN I TALK TO
GOVERNORS TODAY ABOUT HOW WE CAN
IMPROVE THE MISSION.
WE HAVE OTHER CAPABILITIES SUCH
AS OUR HOSPITAL SHIPS, OUR FIELD
HOSPITALS, OUR DEPLOYABLE
EQUIPMENT AND ASSETS.
THE RESERVES IN THE ACTIVE
COMPONENT IF IT GETS TO THAT WAS
HIS LOCALITIES.
THE CHALLENGE THAT WE FACE IS,
SO MUCH OF OUR GEAR AND
CAPABILITIES ARE FOCUSED TOWARDS
TRAUMA.
AT THE SAME TIME, THOSE SAME
HOSPITALS OFTEN DRAW FROM THE
RESERVES WHICH MEANS THE
CIVILIAN WORKFORCE.
WE ARE CONSCIOUS AS WE DEPLOY
FIELD HOSPITALS THAT WE ARE NOT
ROBBING PETER TO PAY PAUL WHEN
IT COMES TO MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS.
AS WE RESPOND TO STATES AND
CITIES AND LOCALITIES WE TO MAKE
SURE WE ARE CONSCIOUS OF WHAT WE
ARE DOING AND THAT WE ARE NOT
CREATING PROBLEMS ELSEWHERE IN